давай таку що він tolich
я запрошую туди у вигляді міністра на
світлі та науки Михайлович підлітків і
як і
шеннон і висновки світу малювати вуха
поза учасником тіла захоплення світлі анни
колеги
міжнародні експерти синів
журналісти я б у шутер хотіла показати
її що навіть добрі що учень України та
Криму прем'єр-міністр цінної кільки за
раді тріумфує реверанс у
справлю розуміти пріоритет несу святі і
c ми побачили у бюджеті дуже складному та
бюджеті алое справедливому бюджеті 2017
урок уколи все-таки о 4 ранку та малі
продування у своєму соціальному статусі
ipad app та внесіть
віджати він вони будуть рубаного в продовж
багатіїв руки
української та незалежності і ми б ви не
разу мід і що оцикет
одне старше коло їм там і шакали
медовим з на всю патологічну граматику
скорим цього ми сьогодні до наук вівці
моєму розумі та що це і людські капітал
дорослу че так вже люди люди і кіпру
цілує зі своїми святими наука
я
з правді esp одягайся щось з
розумінням і ну куди продовжу ось це і
продовжу ось осідали
і буду в тіні, але так вже в пріоритетах
уряду до 2020 руку orgy ключовик
пріоритети відразу милого персі що я хочу
пити крісло цієї ми запакуємо ся в сирію
систем з вид і вид дужки для до святої
та хіба алеф пріоритети нам треба було
включить і те, що вимагатиме війни і
біля води і як шо тут німа душ кельн та його
світи чіпа за шкіль навчилася вигляд і
дорослих цінного означає що він енквен
з дітьми і мокро дечому на плівку поки
щоб спочатку самій таки 4 пріоритети
саяки сну сучасна доступно загальна
середньому сметанного українська школа
модернізація професійно-технічні
квіти за вас печінки і я кістки вища
святі на вас система управління це
фінансова наука
ми провели дуже багато обумовлений по
кожному з їхнього пріоритету тому що
шкіряних пріоритетів
об'єкт а й відповіді не затікав і не
групи та
спицю space слабачка та граматики
адже організації видно по мережі і
пісня ти псих консультації але живі
наклонова редакція цик пріоритет у
точно на і
за раз я хочу суп і не десятих
пріоритетах нова українська школа ми
презентували в цю концепцію та затвердів
та політичний пропозиції кабінету
міністрів зі страти яєчної
пропозиція і в чому суть нової української
школи ми на моїй годині за 1 дозу зрозуміло
стало коротко чоловіком, а сказати його дні
нам важливі vapory ти ж школи чик і
знань до школи не кілька знати а школи
компетентно стояки включає в себе
знання і в мене їх кори 100 ват
для владних по трек для профі сильних
завдань
та індивідуальних особливих сасних завдань
ht крем знай і вмій е7 насті та ставлення
люди на потоці води приватному потоки
інформації по ви на відрив від і в ставку в
сальні середні свити
систему темно стояка допоможе їй
роботи владний ви beer
так допоможе ви рубля ти свої столи не до
потоку всієї інформації за рахунок
критичного мислення та
про славних тінистих 2017 рік для нас
критичних підготовці реформи
а саму ціну вина вчора програми з
чітко ви і школи на компетентні з не
основі пілот увальня програмі
матеріалом оперативник за провалюється
на всю Україну
у нас будуть пілот не школи які будуть
брати краще з'їм експерименті ми миємо
пара петру туго ти в 4 столітті будуть брат і
porsche та клас нової української школи
є 25 тисяч їх севан і пройду через
систему підвищення кваліфікації
доступного у теми 2017 уроки а так вже ми
руйнуємо відкриту середню електронну
платформу ідея пил агаїв тому щоб
ноги початкові матеріали нові стандарти
компонент з моєї школи ми ви клали
онлайн і все, і бочки
ios витян та йди ти малий доступ дацик
матеріалі дуже важливо
елемент унції їй платформи
дистанції не курси будуть
вимова у польську чергу для дітей
що завершилася науку кованих і напій
контрольних територіях м'язи сидить і
навіть часто хоче продовжу ось і вийшов
свиту в Україні
алан мають шанс за роздобудь і україна
знов че предмети там його та мій вигляд
критий для них такі чоловіки вийшли через
дистанційні курси на вигляд критику світло
не платформі ми вже зрубані пальчик рук
і знайшли ходу нової української школи
ми на лузі руку bull і а нові не
програми для початку ви і школи з
елементом та компетентнісного підходу ми
на онлайн-платформу ця ера ви клали
виду вона в мовчанні матеріали для наших
4 ми в бірж і представив і хрестоматію
з у приватні дитину літератури для
пучкові школи топтати та маленькі гіти
ж
очухається і свіжий під них у зграях
помста помста нацере ми плану йому а
на війні початкових програм
школи з 5 9 клас
ми так вже пари для так йому програми та
нововівчарні плани для 10 11 класів
предметно чи дискусія нам важлива в цю
школу старше зруби ти довідки профільну
школу і яко орендована буде потрібно і
дітей яким же роблять владний лібер то
ви я плани будуть продовжити своє освітлення
траєкторію для нас кардинально увійшло його
посили ти природні ніж математичну
свиту і ми хочемо і штуку профіль нею
українській школі було значиш але без і
дітей з початкових закладів віку будуть
апарати для навчання природні ніж
тематичний профіль
цьому ми за розбив стипендію для
студенти вікі навчається на природний
математичних спеціальностей для того
щоб не буду бішма ти вова не кіно
знайти спеціальності алеппо гляньте ми і
інвесту та movable 1 не кабінеті
природні ніж і маткового профілю у
2016-му ряд виділивши 200 мільйонів гривень
піцу ми ту ж цілу руку з 300 мільйонів
гривою на обладнання
математичний природний чиїх кабінетах
у завзятих школах та спеціалізованих
школах а так вже 300 мільйонів гривень для
об'єкт даних територіальних громад
повз і мостом у лева ти вибраний історію
своєї системи us with і
200 мільйонів гривень на автобуси
засадах спи фінансово не випадково в
внаслідок децентралізації багата
дольового напірного життя зварило свити
органами свого самоврядування ми майку
малювати сус або
і в ряду допомагаючи органами з його
самоврядування ось таким і вид по видних
та субвенції ми для стимулювання
конкретних коло нас зустрічей усім
пріоритету модернізація професій на
технічні його почети щоб я повторю ось
а цьому чуду ж добрим було сказано і
прем'єр-міністром віце-прем'єр-міністром
про неї піднеси важливі висіла на премію я
краще хочеш у планети з на конкретних
термінах вибори для дай йому стандарти
професій на вас квіти на ком черевики з
на основі виймає вигляд побачитися
кваліфікаційним вимагом нового ринку
прибрати цього ринку практики з жахливим
і технологіям ми в чому у дітей
можемо враховувати шон обсмажимо дітей на
володіння 70-их руки
а он і будуть у мід і працювати на
володіння з жахливим там у сьогодні в ряд
складу та кофти на обладнання центрі
яким може бути і базовим і кумедним і
спеціальностям і куди може приходить і
біти для розвитку своїх профіль сильних
у меню на приклад за 2016 та доступний
2017 все у майбутнє тут 53 початково
практичніше центри яки створі та музику
що в ряду а так вже розум робота дартс і
ми напружуватися уроку ми володіли та
2 sim центрі назад нас робот вдасться ми
та 25 за кішкою та рядом тримаючи на instead
інвестицій а за це Ерік у ланцюг живлення
100 мільйонів гривень відпал худим едемом
дали нам треба укрупнювати та доповіді профі
сильно технічні про святих добрі
обладнання більше дітей be shy fx &
mysql а даних кішки там у видно пам'ятаю
влади
я кай і на берег 390 вимиємо перейти до
цільового поки що знака 410 що на менше
безпечніше я клас поточні святі царі
форма розхиталася, а відразу персію сама
петля майдану підсипавши перший закон про
ви ще свята кліпу в прийнятій сфері
квіти у 2014 уроки і ми продовжуємо
імплементацію тіла закону Ісус або І
уряду арсеній яценюк від при сотні і
міністр Сергій Квіт ми продовжимо
імплементацію цілей реформи
що сьогодні контент руї масть на харчування
за безпечний
я кістки я поважаю, що ти знайдеш
випробувана кнф
implement a ванну в тому законі та думу
ми парили та йому стандарти на компоненти
з не основі тому що ти маєш matiz
standart & kate і від чого перевіряєш
ми проти неї ми чуємо і початковому і за
скарбом і ціль для нас буде пріоритетом
над системою внутрішнього забезпечення
кістки вийшли з вигляду
б виймає дасть від нього на посмішку
автономію за 1 видно новим законом для
нас у над випадково важливі вузи порожні ти
і національні інстр за забезпечення я
кістки вище та свити
їжі ці хлопці перрі skoda я навіть з
гинув і падала та мною колишнім charge
сам типу skoda ми будемо про реальне від і
агенство і ти будеш совістю вище за нього
почет з гарну репутацію мене на
прикладі від міністра душах в іллю і що
на сьогодні з найкращим узором і суворо на
замовити в будинок і окей перед великою на
дальняк у мартін їх по слух що ми хочемо
врубаєтесь його агенство я люблю що це
треба кардинально пар ілья ну ти і
агентство мої ви канати свою міс століття
було задумано коливанова прописувалася в
законі про вищого світу прозу злочинно
програмою бакалавра та магістрація
уроку отрута ви знаєте у взутті маму
порядку до магістратури право дає
правдиві ви не було кіку руб tener мову
і ми робом упр візерунки за зовнішніми
закладеного оцінювання та дяка та
міжнародним партнерам якісь
допомагаєте нам у тему плані ми так вже
проектуємо він від створу ним національну
репозитарій в академічному тексті
харчування академічного добра чесності
для нас дуже важливо і хочеться поважати
ще минуло уроку
тексти всіх дисертацій перед Христом
про прелюдії ціна сайту до речі
реалізованих цінних рад основі
державний стандарти частина еліс нових
державний стандарт у якому з вини
розрубати і на комп'ютерній основі дати
про вас за краще але ви краще знаки та kiss
викравши
а особи робота інтенсивного на відрив
і я думаю що будемо від і довідник
успіх але вас з тема управління
фінансування наукою виду цю скажу що
мабуть наука і тебе ситуація до сьогодні
позначилося на офіційний білль шимін
пов'язаної нас правді сьогодні держави
фінансування наука 100 нових нігті на
адже сотих вид ВВП для того щоб
наука могла
роздоріжжя ти працювати над фото
фундаментальним дослідженням та
енеску ручку ось і критично і ціль
сектор в садиба ти фінансування
державна що найменша на ремені 0 сили
адже десятих сотка ввп і
у нас був у ставок у нас buff витрачений
незалежної аудит у рамках програми
європейську та гризун 20-20 i've seen
Зайве експерти підтвердили протез що
фінанс увальня наук та в Україні критично
мало і думу - йому відразу їх методика
темпах ми будемо біля доріжки ось і
фінансово не наукою доступні б то ні
акції кішки ви просто ти знайдеш інтер
інтенсивно або тип це не три бари
погляд від і розум вона кікі говорить і про
ефективність бою кашу ми не будемо
порушив втц фінансово не я.
ефективність нам не дасть на лижних
результаті аджи ми плану їм постав
цією на засіданні кабінету міністрів
дорожню карту імплементації закону
україни про наукова на у кого технічно
діянь деми про хуї мої рекомендації
закладеного аудиту
ми джилл уроку запустимо національну
роду випробувати розвитку наука та технології
якубу ти краще люблять і прем'єр-міністр
це буде вперше коли на решці nabucco
серйозно наука був проти проти ти з
учнями влади так ми вже запустимо а
національний фонд якщо джин через окей
буде це і гранту ви фінансово не я і
наша ми тягнемо basic 15 адже сотки
бюджетні кішки і які виділяється на
науку та йшли через національний фонд до
свіжої було відразу мило за раз через
біржан iphone після джині d&d гранту ви
фінансово не йди всього менше 1 вид
сотка кішки яти виділяється на науку 2
адже сотки
вид досі шків на науку ми моєму бачив
це на програми для молодих у члени їх
придбати мальва ти із зуб н.і.
примати у краї не сьогодні таких копій
500к для нас дуже важливо
механізм фінансування до результату
роботи наук нових установок і там ми
зараз зростання проціону йому спину зосима
похити а ми механізм атестації наука
х установ шановний що 2020 уроці ми
можемо про сперму але за я в цій право ти
статтю 89 сотки
установ перед нами дуже багато роботи
all mfp сьогодні що ми можемо у разом птиці
я з роботи я пари кону наша реформа
свята кар'єри форму і на 10 лиття на ер
і форму та кільки групи людей сир та
формою до мого ти прийнята і Петро
манаусі мтс успішності
там уми на ланцюг малюємо ми ж крити і
обладунок брати і хочу сказати що про свято
c і шлях добром агентську з
солідарності а на жаль папку україни ми
можемо досягнутий успіх у самої через
грім агентську солідарність через
інноваційний прорив
який можна труби тієї через науку хочу
також давай сорому вашого відома що
частини на наші пріоритети вікі ми за
пропливав і
наших крутих е про пріоритети наших
міністерств та Микола реально проектуємо
з меншим і міністерством і, наприклад,
інновацій nadia nyce у нас позиційного
на навчання плані у фрагменті я кріс
тусується міністерство економіки all і
тому там інакше пропозиції ми спимо
працювати мама з міністерством економіки
над тим, що їсть йому лева інновації
ну діяльність в Україні так само як
децентралізації у свиті
навіть доброго піщаного кремом у витку
видному розділі dm et sp процедуру йому
дружними міністерством і я одягаєшся
що нам ми згадуємо що ми побуду йому
їжі на поль уточню націю
ми побуду йому інноваційну економіку та
грубому з так вже через про на війну
систему про святі наукою дякую за увагу
мають гітарну рівну